Mr Beast one of his boys transitioning
bro Mr Beast trying to get that Bud
Light sponsorship
[Applause]
which boy though was it the elf looking
[__] or no no the Indian no no wait for
it that's my dude first with with Carl
it was anthatic no the human foot no not
Carlos
safe [__] yeah who is elf Nolan oh you
went with Nolan yeah cause he's he's
pretty you thought that he was close
yeah but is that a is that a is that a
safe way of you saying you were most
attracted to him yes yeah absolutely
he's the most attractive
yo if you put Tark in a [__] what is
that [__] called that free women in
Saudi wear
targeting her job bro he'd be cute he'd
be cute yeah he got a body he got a
romantic eyes who the elf one now oh
[__] you just love white [__]
okay so you're saying of all the the
people on Mr BEAST's channel of all the
town on his channel you thought that it
would be Nolan that would transition
first yes he has the most feminine
features um okay and is he the the
person that you would most like to fill
up his throat with dicks
[Music]
probably first let's start there really
yeah you fill up your ass that's crazy
kind of weird see I try to go gay
pretty much okay yeah now now you're
about it obviously sorry yeah close
enough yeah yeah I'm upset or Jimmy or
Mr Beast I'm just saying bro yeah
bro you've got all the technology
go to Mr Beast he might be I'm just
saying he might be the hottest he's got
all the technology he's got all the
connections you think that Jimmy's
better looking than TARC with the
technology yes with the technology
you're out of your [__] your mind
objectively you think Jimmy yes it is
I think I think if he did it as a
challenge video I think he's got it
gross today
[Music]
yeah man I'm getting a little nervous so
who you like
dude Nolan is beautiful
he's a pretty he's a pretty little [__]
yes the easiest one that can transition
I put Nolan a sundress walk him down the
Ave dude it's over bro we collecting
1500 a night easy with that now a little
bit more exotic yeah yeah yeah he's a
little bit more exotic yeah and I feel
like look at that that's bad pictures yo
you a hater bro
you like this one you like when he
brings you cash get him in a nurse
outfit because that's what he's
transitioning to wait which one which
one right now not down to the left down
to the left Come On Son I got that right
there go that come on yeah oh [__] come
on wow yeah that's General Hospital oh
that's genital Hospital right there bro
let's go wow
now my question is is Mr B's going to
sponsor the final surgery if Chris
elects to do it I think they should do
it as a video they should do last person
take their hand off the dick wins it and
they all put their hands on the dick and
then the last one gets to keep it I
think that'd be
better to do post-op surgery
I think that's fine
[Laughter]
[Music]
every time he goes back what do you
think about that challenge what do you
think about that challenge video I I
think Nolan would win
you think Nolan would win I think you
know he looks like he would hold the
dick the longest Nolan does yeah wow we
really putting gay on Nolan a lot right
now I've been get those vibes at all I
thought it's just he's so soft yes fairy
that's a great Point come on if we're
thinking about mythical beasts the Elven
people and the fairies definitely
closely related y'all are forgetting
Carl though
nah nah okay I forget damn
I'm kidding for all you cutie
he's adorable like you're the least
trans of the group
cute Carl let's go back to that one
right there and zoom in on Carl look how
adorable Carl is that's what I'm saying
he's a little cutie patoots but can you
put the dude that's actually
transitioning because you had a picture
up but that's no fun
it's working bro yo these medications yo
can we give these meds to girls that are
kind of ugly yeah I know I mean
necessarily before we address this
picture hold on one second hold on now
we saw that right can we get there are
medications right that we can give to
men
biological men and they become prettier
versions of themselves what is stopping
us from just giving these medications to
uglier women and them becoming prettier
versions rounding up the fours that's it
I'm
that's genius
fantastic transition into a fine [__]
why can't we do that let's do that
there's some dudes that need to just
offer that up to shorties like right
there yo I love you yeah I love you but
you're regular yeah yeah
HRT come on let's get you on the PDS I I
mean look at what just happened to Chris
look how beautiful Chris is compared to
when he was a guy
come on yo
come on yo go back to when he's a girl
pretty little librarian come on oh God
right there ow come on you were born in
three and four of them
oh come on now
got a little more to go he got a little
more to go but the headband looks
adorable Amish yeah you know how you
could turn that butter you're not gonna
let him turn
come on come on